ici on parle chinois à l'extérieur de
cette épicerie de nuit de dijon la
pancarte annonce la couleur
les touristes chinois sont les bienvenus
mais depuis une quinzaine de jours ils
ont disparu on a à côté de la gare
routière donc où les bus se stationnent
et quand ils arrivent ici donc c'est
leur premier point de passage se fait au
coco rico dans cette épicerie là et donc
ils sont attirés par nos produits locaux
les fruits les légumes tout ça est en
général où ils arrivent ils sont une
cinquantaine quotidiennement sinon
presque et c'est vrai que là depuis
depuis deux trois semaines en europe et
l'inquiétude est d'autant plus forte que
la situation semble vouloir durer dans
cet hôtel à beaune un tiers de la
clientèle à cette époque de l'année
chinoise des voyageurs en groupes de
passage souvent pour une nuit mais
toutes les réservations étaient annulées
depuis fin janvier et jusqu'à fin mars
les résultats de l'établissement en
pâtissent évidemment et le temps on dit
que c'est fin mars mais le temps que
les groupes se remette en marche que les
aéroports se remette en marche
ça va impacter les mois d'avril mai très
vraisemblablement le sujet est au coeur
de toutes les discussions chez ces
professionnels du tourisme réunis au
siège de leur organisation
les comptes ne sont pas bons sur dijon
et beaune ce sont entre 5 et 6000
nuitées qui ont déjà été annulés et des
revenus définitivement perdu c'est une
période où effectivement la
fréquentation touristique est
essentiellement chinoises je rappelle
que nous avons la chance à dijon et
beaune d'être lé deuxième ville
française fréquentée par les touristes
chinoise qui est une chance
extraordinaire
et malheureusement cette clientèle là
aujourd'hui et irremplaçable pour les
deux mois qui viennent
en attendant la reprise des vols depuis
la chine les professionnels font contre
mauvaise fortune bon coeur et se rassure
en espérant que sitôt la crise du
coronavirus passé les touristes viennent
plus nombreux encore